The only thing that comes to mind specific to this group, I know your introduction was about cancer, but I'm aligning and we can, we can cover this tomorrow if you want that to be the, the, the venue, but, and some of the materials that I've read from your website,
Align will, my words probably not technical for you, but will change its frequency over time.
How often do we need to have a check back with you to make sure that the line protocols we're using on our right are still the right concoction.
So a couple things will determine that the biggest thing is how you're doing.
So if I have a line patient and they are stay there, they feel like they're staying stable or they're slowly improving, then we may change the frequencies to up how much kill we got in overnight program.
So line programming for the right is extremely different than a cancer program.
Because in a cancer program, we could put, we're attempting to quote unquote kill the cancer with the right frequencies and the way a cancer cell is going to die with the right is going to stimulate a poptosis.
And that you will not get any quote unquote a hoax cyber reaction from the cancer cells died with light disease, you're dealing not with your normal cell, you're dealing with a bacteria.
So we're killing that.
And it's a gram negative, which has a lipo polysaccharide in the cell membrane, and when you kill it, you're going to liberate that, lipo polysaccharide, if that's going to stimulate an immune reaction, that's going to cause difficulty in getting it out of the liver cell, you're going to have that for cyber reaction.
So we don't want to kill too fast.
I know I speak to you, or with any live patient, they go, I'm doing really well, but I feel like it's kind of plateaued.
Then I'll say, OK, then I'm going to tweak your program.
We're going to add the amount of time that we're doing kill.
And we're going to push this a little bit harder.
If the patient says, if the patient says, so there's three things that could happen to patients, I'm doing horrible.
Then I might change the dwell where we're going to go slower.
Number two, they say, I'm doing well, but I feel like I'm plateaued.
Then I'm going to change the dwell where we're going to go faster.
Number three, they say, I'm doing fantastic.
Then I'm going to say, OK, well, it's not change anything.
The frequency doesn't move. It's just the duration or dwell.
Well, the frequency may move because lots of times I'll get some, you know, what I add some was I maybe do some distance testing.
I may add some empty bar. I may add some other other co infections.
They help the person too. So there's a with live there's a lot of tweaking that that can be done.
So whether a person's speed up or they're not doing well, we could do a lot of tweaking.
OK, we'll probably talk more tomorrow than thank you.
Thank you.